the rain did not stop thousands of
people from gathering outside guftavo
petros headquarters
the economist and former left-wing
guerrilla won the elections with just
over 50 percent of the votes
it's a new era in colombia the first
time a left-wing candidate has won the
presidency
i want to cry this is the first time we
are going to have a popular government
from the left from the people of those
who have suffered the armed conflict and
he is someone who represents us the
people on the streets
these people have been demanding change
in this country where liberals and
conservatives have been sharing power
for years
in colombia like re-thinking the war on
drugs rethinking oil and gas
exploitation and fighting inequality and
that's why all these people are
celebrating his victory because they
believe that this is the beginning of a
process of change
this was petro's third presidential bid
he's now a seasoned politician whose
victory at colombia to the list of latin
american countries that have elected
center-left presidents in recent years
on sunday evening he was presented to
his supporters by his running mate
francia marquez who will be colombia's
first afro-colombian woman vice
president
we are writing history right now a new
history for latin america what is coming
here is change real change in which we
commit to life itself we are not going
to disenchant our voters that have been
screaming that from now on colombia
changes petro defeated 77-year-old
populist rodol fernandez who was
referred by many as the king of tik-tok
but petro will face many challenges 47
percent of the country did not vote for
him
analysts say he will have to negotiate
his reforms in congress this is not only
the first time that a left-wing
candidate has been elected in colombia
but also the first time that we have a
left-wing
congress too because back to historical
the social movement behind gustavo peter
was able to elect
a good number of congress members so he
will have
a congress that is in favor of him not a
complete majority he doesn't have a
majority in congress but he has a good
number of congress members and that is
also something that uh signs that he
could have a success in his tournament
pedro will take office in august for
many his government will empower the
people in the country who have been
ignored by authorities for years
teresa